senna bonjour et bienvenue dans
parlement m dos l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat et que
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter avec
brigitte boucher bonjour brigitte un
jour ta main et cette semaine a été
encore marqué par le cos vie par les
débits des travaux de la commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale mais
aussi l'impact économique de la pandémie
on va revenir sur tous ces sujets avec
notre invité marc regev nous bonjour
orge où vous êtes député la république
en marche de l'essonne et c'est brigitte
qui vous présente ma rigueur nous
bonjour libéral vous entré en politique
en 99 au sein des démocraties libérales
avec alain madelin dont vous devenez la
collaboratrice parlementaire vous
présidez aussi le mouvement les jeunes
avec madelin avant de rejoindre l'ump à
sa création en 2002 où vous prenez là
aussi la tête du mouvement des jeunes
pop qui chantait vouloir changer le
monde vous entrez en sus d'un cour des
grands au sein des cabinets ministériels
à coopération puis à l'écologie vous
êtes alors catalogué comme une fidèle
d'alain juppé que vous soutenez dans la
course à la présidentielle en 2016 avant
d'intégrer l'équipe de campagne de
françois fillon le gagnant de la
primaire mais face aux affaires vos
origines amiénoise vous amène évidemment
à vous tourner vers emmanuel macron en
2018 on vous confie le poste de
rapporteur des deux projets de loi de
révision constitutionnelle et bien qu'en
est il de cette prouesse au projet de
révision constitutionnelle ah bah
écoutez pour l'instant il n'est pas
inscrit à l'ordre
à l'ordre du jour mais
mais ça le sujet de la réforme
institutionnelle forcément sera fait
forcément partie des champs de réflexion
qui sont qui sont les nôtres
pourtant aussi difficile de changer la
constitution on voit que la convention
citoyenne rend ses conclusions ce week
end justement et propose de changer la
constitution pour intégrer le
dérèglement climatique dans tous les
projets de loi qui pourrait se faire
désormais est-ce que ça ça doit être
intégrée dans la constitution
je crois d'abord que sur la sur la
convention citoyenne faut saluer l'idée
même qui a présidé à sa création vous
souvenez ça avait été cela été mis en
place à la suite du grand débat et puis
l'idée avait été de rassembler 150
citoyens qui pourraient s'investir sans
question aujourd'hui sont en train de
rendre leurs premières leur conclusion
il ya un vote qui se passe je crois ce
week-end où ils vont devoir faire des
propositions et puis ce sera ensuite à
nous au parlement ou par la voie de
référendum qui souvent évoquées
notamment un référendum à cette
hypothèse je je je je suis en tout cas
persuadé d'une chose c'est que le sujet
de la préservation de l'environnement et
de la biodiversité c'est pas un nouveau
sujet extrêmement longtemps qu'on en
parle et il pense en inquiète qu'on s'en
alarme et que pour autant on voit bien
qu'on a un certain nombre de choses
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire souvient de
l'écotaxe par exemple plus récemment de
la taxe carbone on voit bien que imposer
des décisions par le haut sur ce sujet
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour autant
il faut qu'on avance sur ce sujet et
donc tant qu'on n'arrivera pas à faire
en sorte que les français se sentent
réellement concernés par ce sujet je
pense que c'est très de faire un dogme
c'est le moyen de le référendum est
parti directement les petites scènes
même si on sait que ça peut devenir un
effectivement le référendum moyens
manuels macro on sait que c'est aussi le
risque des réseaux politiques
les référendums ya toujours des risques
mais je crois que ce n'est pas le sujet
une sujet c'est que sur ceux sur cette
question essentielle qui est la
préservation de l'environnement
encore une fois on n'a pas trouvé
jusqu'à maintenant les moyens d'avancer
quel que soit le parti qui quelle que
soit la majorité
on a avancé petit pas par petit pas il
ya des choses qui ont été faites et qui
ont été bien faites mais on voit bien
qu'à un moment ses buts probablement
parce que d'ailleurs les français n'ont
pas la même appréciation du problème en
fonction de leur territoire moi je suis
élu de l'essonne
l'environnement c'est quelque chose qui
est je pense chevillée au corps de la
plupart des concitoyens de ma
circonscription parce que lors que le
contact avec la nature est probablement
plus compliquée que si j'étais élu du
cantal
donc voilà donc la pression est
différente il faut réussir à faire en
sorte que cette question elles viennent
elles soient être prise en main on se
bat mais ce référendum
je pense que le référendum par
consultation c'est effectivement quelque
chose qui serait de nature à régler ce
problème
les maris gay venez on va revenir sur
les temps forts de cette semaine est
d'abord la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire le 10 juillet faux répondent
les députés qui juge les restrictions
qui accompagne le projet de loi trop
contraignante la commission d' enquête
sur la gestion du coc vie 19 a démarré
ses travaux à l'assemblée les
responsabilités sur les stocks de
masques ne sont pas encore établies
certains députés sont restés sur leur
faim après la pandémie la relance toutes
les formations politiques à gauche comme
à droite planche sur leurs propositions
pour faire repartir l'économie pour les
sénateurs aient l'air leur est tout
protectionnisme et on commence cette
émission avec la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
[Musique]
le projet de loi visant à mettre fin à
l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 10 juillet
a été adoptée en première lecture à
l'assemblée cette semaine certaines
mesures de restrictions demeurent
néanmoins jusqu'au 30 octobre pour les
oppositions de droite comme de gauche
c'est un texte liberticide les
précisions d'elsa mon magasin pour le
gouvernement pas question de sortir du
jour au lendemain de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui prend fin le 10 juillet
prochain
cette sortie l'état d'urgence sanitaire
doit être organisée parce que la
vigilance reste de mise et que de
nombreuses mesures restent nécessaires
dans les prochains mois notre position
doit être une position de responsabilité
l'état d'urgence n'est plus justifiée
dans son intégralité mais ne pas
conserver certaines mesures ce serait
faire comme si les risques de
redémarrage de l'épidémie n'existait pas
or ces risques existent ce projet de loi
met donc en place un état transitoire
jusqu'au 30 octobre prochain
ce que dénoncent les oppositions l'état
d'urgence il est où il n'est pas un état
d'urgence
ça se déclare où ça se lève alors si
vous ne levait pas assumé donc de le
maintenir ce texte permettent au
gouvernement de conditionner l'accès aux
transports en obligeant le port du
masque par exemple de restreindre les
déplacements
le gouvernement souhaitait également
pouvoir continuer à interdire les
rassemblements mais il a dû revoir sa
copie après la décision du conseil
d'état
pour l'opposition les restrictions
restent trop importantes que dans le
pire de la crise
l'assemblée a été unanime pour vous
autoriser à prendre ces mesures
dérogatoires
mais on va pas vivre éternellement sous
ce régime attentatoire à anneaux à nos
libertés
donc il faut trouver d'autres
instruments juridiques beaucoup moins
intrusif que ce que vous êtes en train
de prendre votre conception de la
liberté nous fait quand même
sérieusement réfléchir compte tenu de la
circulation importante du virus
la guyane et mayotte reste elle sous
état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 30
octobre prochain
marc regev nous est ce que ce projet de
loi c'est la continuation finalement de
l'état d'urgence par d'autres moyens
l'état d'urgence sanitaire il prend fin
le 11 juillet il a été prorogé par la
loi du 11 mai jusqu'au
donc il ya les vrais mondialisation qui
accompagne ce projet donne jusqu'au 30
octobre et le en juillet l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prendra fin ensuite
le projet de loi dont on parle celui qui
est examinée en ce moment il porte sur
trois mesures qui sont effectivement
restrictive réglementation de la
circulation par exemple de fermeture
d'établissements publics
il faut comprendre que c'est une boîte à
outils un cadre législatif général que
l'on actionne ponctuellement de façon
chirurgicale
dans le cas où une résurgence de
l'épidémie sur des clusters très
localisé cette boîte à outils est elle
vraiment nécessaire est ce que si bien
y'a l'épidémie à nouveau il faut pas
simplement déclaré l'état d'urgence
c'est ce qu'on vous dit ça peut être
fait ça peut être fait très rapidement
c'est ce qui a été fait en début de la
pandémie
je suis pas sûr que ce soit plus
favorable à nos libertés que de
déclencher l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour l'ensemble du territoire parce que
on aurait un cluster qui viendrait à
paraître dans telle ville de france
c'est pas ça l'objet on avait par
ailleurs vers des zones à gauche on a
bien fait des zones différentes même pas
les zones vertes et les zones rouges
c'est pas l'état d'urgence ça c'est
quand même pas pareil oui d'accord
non non non mais ça laisse penser qu'il
y aurait une deuxième vague étoiles
belle si situe du coup de main en fait
les éléments il faut rendu public qui
montrent peut les consulter
c'est l'avis du conseil scientifique les
deux derniers avis sont très clairs ils
établissent quatre scénarios un qui est
extrêmement pessimiste qui nécessiterait
le déclenchement de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire on souhaite bien sûr que ça
n'arrive pas et trois scénarios qui sont
beaucoup plus optimistes de façon
nuancée en fonction des scénarios bien
sûr mais qui sont plus optimistes et qui
disent très clairement qu'on a besoin de
poursuivre des mesures du type le port
du masque dans les transports en commun
qu'on a besoin d'avoir la capacité de
pouvoir de façon très localisée limiter
la circulation dans le cas où un cluster
viendrait à paraître c'est très
clairement détaillé donc ces outils en
fait ils n'ont ils ne sont pas hors sol
prix parce que personne ne nous les
demanderait l'avis du conseil
scientifique le dis très clairement on a
besoin d'un certain nombre d'outils ou
le temps de réactivité face au virus si
jamais il venait à ressurgir et
déterminant et vous entendez les
craintes les craintes de l'opposition
d'une traîne une inscription durable de
ces mesures d'exception dans notre droit
commun comme ça avait pu être fait et
bien avec la loi citée l'état d'urgence
sécuritaire en 2000
15 évidemment que j'entends les craintes
de l'opposition
mais la présentation binaire qui
consiste à dire on était en état de ce
que dit monsieur gignac on est en état
d'urgence on l'est pas c'est pas vrai on
est pas on est on est face au virus du
corps on est face au virus du cockpit 19
ou on ne l'est pas le 19 est toujours là
ce que dit m c'est que c'est vrai en
2015 ya eu les attentats et puis en 2017
il ya eu cette loi s'il que vous avez ou
certaines dispositions de l'état
d'urgence sont entrés dans le droit
commun on a l'impression duré qu'un
petit d'abidjan et bien on grignote sur
les libertés publiques est ce que vous
ne pensez pas que tout cela finalement
finira par rentrer dans dans le dans le
droit commun on sait évidemment poser
toutes ces questions parce que c'est
essentiel
l'état d'urgence sanitaire on la borne
est dans le temps le 1er avril 2021
l'état d'urgence sanitaire dans la loi
il n'existe plus il est borné dans le
temps est ce que le parlement voudra à
la lumière du travail qui a été de
l'autre se doter d'un état d'urgence
sanitaire entre guillemets pérenne sur
la base du secteur peut-être mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui
cet état d'urgence sanitaire il est
bordé dans le temps et à l'intérieur
c'était agence sanitaire il ya ce
dispositif transitoire là sous laquelle
on est travail qui lui est bordé dans le
temps 30 octobre voilà ce dont on parle
on parle pas de quelque chose de pérenne
de 2010 pâques le conseil d'état quand
même freiner vos ardeurs dans
l'interdiction des rassemblements
ça veut dire que les rassemblements sont
autorisés à partir du 11 juillet le
conseil d'état
il a certes dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
interdire grassement puisqu'on n'était
plus en état de catastrophe sanitaire de
tout à fait dit ça mais il a aussi dit
qu'il fallait que l'on s'assure que les
gestes barrière pouvait être assurée et
que la jauge de 5000 participants à ces
rassemblements devaient être elle aussi
garanti et c'est pour ça que j'ai
proposé un amendement qui justement à
garantir le droit de manifestation mais
a créé un régime d'autorisation
préalable qui permet de s'assurer que
les organisateurs de la manifestation
s'assurant bien que les gestes barrières
sont bien garantie et que les
participants première limite à 5000
alors pour cette émission avec la
commission d' enquête sur le chaos vide
[Musique]
les premières auditions de la mission
d'information doté de pouvoirs d'enquêté
sur le co vie de 19 ans eut lieu cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale le
directeur général de la santé ou le
responsable de santé publique france ont
tenté d'éclairer les députés sur la
gestion des masques les précisions de
stéphanie des pierres jérôme salomon été
le premier à passer sur le gril estimé
vous sur le directeur général que notre
pays était prêt face à ce que nous avons
vécu nous trouvent difficilement un pays
qui a été près le directeur général de
la santé n'a pas expliqué pourquoi au
début de l'épidémie en janvier il n'y
avait que 115 millions de masques
le lendemain l'ancien directeur de santé
publique france confirme qu'il a bien
prévenu jérôme salomon du mauvais état
du stock des masques en 2018
en réponse il a reçu l'ordre d'en
détruire la majeure partie est d'en
acheter 100 millions seulement
loin du milliard préconisé par les
experts je pense qu'il n'y avait dans le
processus de décision
toute une série de personnes qui
pensaient pas réellement à l'utilité des
masques en population et je pense que
c'est ça qui a fait basculer le fait que
la cible n'était plus le milliard mais
la sib étaient quelques centaines de
millions autre interrogation soulevée
par les députés fallait-il confiné tout
le pays jeudi le conseil scientifique a
défendu sa décision
on n'avait pas le choix parce que
l'urgence était dans les réanimations on
avait vu affluer des patients dans un
nombre tout à fait inhabituelle avec des
formes cliniques extrêmement sévère de
pneumopathies inflammatoires pour le
président du conseil scientifique un
dépistage massif n'aurait pas changé la
donne
les auditions continuent à la semaine
prochaine la plus attendue c'est celle
du controversé professeur didier raoult
ce sera mercredi marc regev nous est ce
que jérôme salomon le directeur général
de la santé a failli dans la gestion des
masques on peut pas présenter
pardon mais la question fait réagir
qu'elle est faite pour ça on ne peut pas
présenter les choses de façon aussi
manichéenne ou binaire csn moment il a
il était directeur de la santé il a été
confronté comme nous tous à une crise
dont chacun des français comprendra
qu'elle était inédite majeur sur lequel
il ya aucun pays au monde qui a l'air
d'avoir pu l'anticiper et donc nous pas
plus que les autres et chacun a fait du
mieux qu'il pouvait je reviendrai quand
même sur les chiffres qui ont été donnés
seulement 100 millions de masques
chirurgicaux commandé à l'été 2010 9
pour reconstituer le stock stratégique
de l'état qui avait chuté de plus de 700
millions
c'était quand même une erreur vous le
reconnaissez c'était on peut aller
jusqu'à une faute non je ne reconnaîtrai
rien d'abord je suis pas directeur
général la santé nih me sentais je n'ai
pas suffisamment connaissance
défait pour me prononcer sur quoi que ce
soit ensuite je considère que comme une
erreur stratégique que l'armée s'est
passé ensuite j'ai lu j'ai lu pendant là
pendant la crise de confinement j'ai lu
les témoignages le revenu une bachelot
et de philippe douste-blazy
c'était amusant il dit il écrivait à
l'époque la stratégie qui consistait à
se doter des moyens maximale pour
aborder la crise il disait très
clairement que à l'époque où ils ont mis
en place il passé pour des pour des
originaux et des gens extrêmement
critique et il n'y a pas ici on veut on
veut faire apprécier cette crise comme
si tous démarré au fond aujourd'hui qui
avait pas eu de décision préalable qu'
il n'y avait pas un certain nombre de
mécanismes de notre fonctionnement
global
je dis pas qu'ils sont bien je dis pas
qu'ils ne doivent pas être remis en
cause je dis pas qu'il est examinée mais
il faut arrêter d'avoir un
fonctionnement binaire en pensant que ce
qui nous arrive aujourd'hui n'est que la
conséquence de fait qui sont il y avait
une doctrine qui était qu'il fallait
qu'il ya un stock stratégique d'un
milliard de masques au on exulte obs en
117 et je comprends à la jeune et je
comprends à la réponse de monsieur c'est
le mans qui parle d'un stock renouvelle
façon tournante est en effet un
changement de doctrine parce que je
comprends est-ce que c'était plus
pertinent s'il n'avait pas eu le public
tri nous c'est un problème financier est
ce qu'à un moment on s'est dit
finalement on va peut-être pas mettre
les moyens pour reconstituer un stock
d'un milliard qui va peut-être devenir
obsolètes et dont on n'aura pas besoin
du d'autres priorités voilà je comprends
là je comprends la question je pense pas
qu'elle se soit posée en ces termes je
pense que quand roselyne bachelot pour
prendre cet exemple là fait la commande
d'un certain de matériel pousser au
maximum que ça paraît à l'époque
disproportionnée au point qu'on la moke
si j'en crois ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
dit que pendant des années il semblerait
que non en n'ayant pas eu usage et que
on se retrouve du coup en situation de
se dire bon au fond est-ce que c'était
la bonne stratégie
probablement car le quran à virus en
célibat il semblerait que non vu des
fonds bien d'année au vu des 10
dernières années est étonnant je trouve
ça plutôt au sud ce qui devrait
continuer je trouve ça plutôt bon signe
je vais vous dire quand ce qu'on se
repose la question
deux des politiques que l'on met en
place et comme on va le faire là à la
suite du corner vieille c'est évident
que du coup à la lumière de ce qui est
arrivé
on va se reposer la question de comment
on doit avoir un stock de masques
est-ce que c'est tournant est ce que
c'est pas tournant je pense que les deux
et c'est ça c'est ça à gouverner en fait
ça donne sur le fait qu'en début de
pandémie est bien le gouvernement et dit
que les masques étaient inutiles pour le
grand public est ce que pour vous ça
tout de même bien c'est une c'est une
erreur c'est une faute dans l'opposition
par deux scandales d'état oui mais il
faudrait de l'opposition il n'est pas
parce qu'on est les dames la pression
aussi ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle écoute
ce que disaient les scientifiques nous
faut agir le gouvernement c'est pas une
assemblée docteur le gouvernement il
fait confiance à la parole scientifique
si la parole scientifique et au départ
de dire on ne constate pas au début de
l'épidémie que le masque est
particulièrement nécessaire dans le port
de masques et je me suis même de débat
on disait même que le port du masque
pouvait même être aggravant parce que
les gens se sentant protégées
considérable et le mettant mal se
considérait qu'en fait il n'était plus
lié tenus de faire de gestes barrières
mais tout ce débat là il a existé
après c'est toujours facile d'arriver
après de dire ah c'est scandaleux on
aurait dû avoir un discours on aurait dû
avoir des matières variées qui l'attend
il ya 20 oui mais c'est tout ça c'est
ridicule au fond c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe
c'est pas vrai vous pensez que cette
commission est là pour but d'aller
chercher des coupables
oui je pense que la commission denquête
elles ont elles ont enfin je ne je vais
essayer de répondre à son plaisir si je
pense quand la commission denquête il ya
tout type de démarche et des démarches
qui sont celles du contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement de contrôler un fait et
je pense que c'est bien que le parlement
puisse faire valoir
son droit à se contrôler même son devoir
de contrôle dans ce cas à mon sens
maintenant des commission denquête qui
se fait rare avant et qui ont tendance à
devenir beaucoup plus courante
aujourd'hui qui du coup déprécié au fond
leur action et qui souvent font utilisé
pour des raisons plus politiciennes au
fond et ça je trouve que ça détourne un
peu l'objet l'idée ce n'est pas de
savoir si un coupable ou pas et je dis
pas ça parce que chez la majorité
l'idée c'est de savoir comment on peut
tirer des enseignements de ce qui nous
arrive et réussir à progresser ensemble
c'est ça le sujet allez on avance dans
cette émission
et pour terminer le plan de relance des
sénateurs les républicains alors que le
gouvernement a présenté son troisième
budget rectificatif sous le signe de la
relance
toutes les formations politiques à
gauche comme à droite planche sur leurs
propositions pour faire repartir
l'économie
pour les sénateurs les républicains
l'arrêt tout protectionnisme jonathan du
prix m100 propositions pour un nouveau
départ c'est ainsi que bruno retailleau
qualifie le plan de relance de
l'économie des sénateurs allaient
représenter cette semaine ce plan est à
disposition du président et du
gouvernement pour relever la france
c'est un triptyque nouvelle prospérité
nouvelle solidarité et nouvelle
souveraineté
parmi les propositions notables bruno
retailleau plaide pour une
relocalisation de la production en
france et en europe notamment sur la
question des médicaments
l'idée est d'encourager la préférence
européenne ou française
les l air propose aussi une fiscalité
bleu blanc rouge c'est-à-dire exonérés
d'impôt de 50 à 100 % les entreprises
qui investiraient dans des secteurs
stratégiques en france le plan remettent
aussi au goût du jour une vieille
ficelle sarkozyste le fameux travailler
plus pour gagner plus la droite
sénatoriale aimerait garantir un
treizième mois aux plus modestes
moyennant un temps de travail passant de
35 à 37 heures par semaine je crois que
c'est une recette qui avait marché et
donc il n'est pas interdit de remettre
des recettes qui font plaisir
elles font plaisir mais elles sont aussi
très utiles nous avons besoin d'un choc
de productivité et c'est une des façons
pour que le travail soit plus productifs
et aussi plus rémunérateurs ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir plus de consommation
et aussi d'avoir de meilleurs
compétitivité
nos entreprises une batterie de mesures
jetés comme des ballons d'essai à
destination de l'exécutif
alors ma regev nous qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ces ballons d'essai
relocalisation fiscalité
bleu-blanc-rouge préférence française et
européenne on peut trouver des consensus
je pense qu'en tout cas c'est toujours
bien que l'opposition face au rôle et
puis donne les propositions après est ce
qu'on peut trouver des consensus sur les
rues locales à l'avenir l'avenir le dira
mais oui mais non mais effectivement
freeze dans la toile voilà je trouve que
dans le les annonces du président de la
république m j'allais dire que moi une
retailleau a probablement écouter le
président la république et c'est très
bien il ya déjà en effet des pistes qui
vont qui vont dans ce sens ça est ce que
ce sera reprendra ou pas les
propositions de sénateur l'avenir le
dira mais on voit on voit bien que on
voit bien qu'il ya dans la volonté de
plus dans la république effectivement
d'avoir une question soit souveraineté
dans le plan de relance duquel et quels
sont les secteurs on garde une forme de
souveraineté qui nous a fait défaut
dans le cadre de la crise il là il a
très clairement dit quels sont les
secteurs où on va investir de façon à
créer des nouveaux emplois alors même
que on sait que la rentrée de septembre
octobre va être difficile avec des
paires tenant pas comment on fait pour
préserver l'emploi et en créer de
nouveaux il a donné un gros cadre je
pense qu'il va y avoir le plan des
sénateurs et l'air ils disent qu'ils
reprennent cette idée nicolas sarkozy de
du travailler plus pour gagner plus
on a entendu le président de la
république dire il va falloir travailler
davantage et produire demande à
l'occasion télévisé de dimanche dernier
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire 37 heures
payées 35
on n'est pas encore dans le temps de la
précision des annonces je vais pas je
vais pas faire la prière nous a dit
qu'on pouvait pas faire de la
prospective il ya clairement il ya
clairement un mois ce que j'entends
quand le président de la république dit
ça c'est la situation va être difficile
pour un certain nombre de secteurs
il faut que les syndicats et les chefs
d'entreprise discutent ensemble pour
préserver l'emploi il va falloir
construire monte
il va falloir qu'on se retrousse les
manches pour travailler tous ensemble en
même temps les 35 heures ou pas je peux
pas vous dire je crois pas je sais mon
sentiment mais mais mais je vous dis
être pas personnellement favorable c'est
j'étais pas favorable aux 35 heures au
moment où elles ont été décidées
donc pourquoi pas rouvrir les débats
oui après il ya des débats qui sont qu'
il faut pas forcément réouvrir sans moi
personne à être favorable à titre
personnel je pense que beaucoup de
français qui travaillent beaucoup plus
que 35 heures sauriez favorable à
revenir sur les 35 heures non je ne sais
pas s'il faut revenir c'est en tous cas
me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit mais que dit qu'effectivement il ya
plus tôt la question de comment on
produit on travaille plus effectivement
ça peut faire partie des deux deschamps
je suis pas sûr que ce soit dépensé on
va terminer avec la loi a vient
largement retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel les sages saisis par des
sénateurs et lait restant triste ont
censuré l'obligation de retrait des
contenus haineux sous 24 heures c'était
la mesure phare du texte
les juges constitutionnels ont estimé
que la mesure constitue une atteinte à
la liberté d'expression qui n'est ni
nécessaire ni adaptée ni proportionnée à
reggane où est ce que c'est un camouflet
pour votre majorité
ces noms c'est par un camouflé c'est pas
c'est pas comme ça que je vis jamais les
choses comme ça à vrai dire je crois que
retoquage de la mesure princesse et un
rex qui était important pour votre
majorité c'était un texte qui était
important effectivement pour la députée
viallet le mérite de mettre d'ailleurs
de pointer le sujet qui est la haine en
ligne tout le monde qui est un sujet
nouveau
en tout cas notre versoix le parlement
sans pas c'est un sujet extrêmement
difficile ça a le mérite encore une fois
de braque les projecteurs sur un sujet
qui préoccupe beaucoup de français sur
beaucoup de beaucoup d'aspects à la
décision du conseil constitutionnel est
effectivement très clair et s'il est mal
écrit mais il se doit et doit être
complètement vidé de ses doigts d'avoir
incité un doit inciter si on reprend le
plus est là si on reprend la plume à à
le faire en suivant précisément les
prescriptions du conseil constitutionnel
donc il faut la réécrire cette
proposition de loi il faudra en tout cas
oui il faudra ici si on veut la
redéposer il faudra leur écrire allonger
le délai de 24 heures sur quoi on va
changer pour vous non mais pas le
conseil constitutionnel donne des
indications très clair vous l'avez dit
vous-même
donc il suffira au fond de suivre ses
indications pour les redéposer
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui elle et elle
n'est pas promu gables en état et donc
si on re dépossède proposition de loi il
faudra suivre le cardio il y avait donc
atteinte à la liberté d'expression c'est
ce que dit finalement le conseil
constitutionnel alors qu'il devrait y
avoir un consensus sur une telle
proposition de loi sur la haine en ligne
oui je comprends que je comprends que le
conseil constitutionnel considère qu'en
effet une atteinte à la liberté
d'expression dès lors que le temps qui
qui est donné aux opérateurs pour
laisser le contenu et qui est à leur
seule appréciation est une entorse à la
liberté d'expression je comprends que
c'est effectivement ce que les conseils
constitutionnels principal argument des
opposants ce texte vous regrettez de ne
pas les avoir écoutés parce que le
l'objectif il était partagé par tous
mais pas le moyen ce qui est ce qui est
très compliqué dans le fait de regretter
de salut les oppositions
très souvent ils disent des choses
pertinentes et parfois beaucoup moins au
contraire pas qu'il dise des choses pas
forcément pertinente voilà il se trouve
que la nd a mis un point qui était
pertinent
probablement qu'on a dû être faire
preuve de plus d coûte faire preuve de
plus des coûts de merci marie gueye no
mercy tam tran huy merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro deux
parlements et or
[Musique]